spare death destruction
this is even bigger than the last crisis
the official Foundation season 2 trailer
is here and to no one's surprise it
looks great there seems to be no
shortage of elaborate set pieces coming
our way and you won't hear me
complaining about that as I mentioned in
my season 2 teaser breakdown it's a
little tricky to guess where any of this
is heading because season one ended with
that epilogue of salvor and Gale meeting
130 years later I'm inclined to think
that everything we see here is that far
in the future with all the timelines
synced up why do I think that well there
is a lot of either impending or active
conflict in this trailer and you would
have to imagine that the foundation
would need those hundred years that have
been mentioned in the promo materials to
get prepared so that any conflict
wouldn't end in Slaughter also the
Empire's power needs to decline which
might be related to the decay of the
ruling cleons's genetic Purity that we
saw set in motion at the end of season
one still there's no guarantee T that
the new season will be structured that
way and where it gets even trickier to
guess is that we do see some of the new
characters that were cast for this
season who are involved in different
parts of the story before we get into
what we see in this trailer let's
briefly look at how the story was laid
out in asimov's books the book
Foundation hurled through time over its
five parts season one of the show
completed the first two of those the
psycho-historians which was Harry and
Gail's introduction and their arrest on
trantor which led to the Exile and then
the encyclopedists which covered the
development of terminus there were also
some aspects of the third part the
Mayors but that's where the story
diverged in a serious way when Sabor
left Terminus to go looking for her
biological mother Gail rather than
staying and becoming a key mayor in the
foundation's development this is where I
could clarify that this is more of a
remix than a direct adaptation I'm sure
I'm gonna get dozens of comments
pointing this out but I think it's worth
mentioning that two of the characters we
get our first glimpse of here are from
those first two books Hoover Milo is
from the part titled the merchant
princes and Bell Rios is from the part
titled the general their timelines in
the books don't really overlap but we
might see the show condense some things
I guess what's important as far as the
story is concerned is that the second
half of the first book and the first
half of the second were focused on how
the foundation develops and expands its
influence Beyond Terminus how they do
that evolves and involves Superior
attack a church of scientism economic
power through trading and so on each
advancement creates unique challenges
and as the foundation evolves to deal
with those they also have to deal with
the Selden crises that psycho history
predicted can I connect those same dots
with what I see in the trailer not
exactly but other than the stuff that
was added to the show to keep the same
characters around longer things like the
genetic Dynasty and Harry's
Consciousness still being around if I
put that to the side I can't rule out
that they'll still pick up on some of
the key points from the Mayors the
Traders and the merchant princes before
they move into the general
so what's actually in the trailer it
opens with a shot of Gale on a new
planet who tells us in voiceover that
she has dreams sometimes about things
that will happen and she wakes up
terrified we have a shot of her with
salvor on synax where we left him at the
end of season one Gail's childhood home
is mostly underwater now and they had
seemed stranded but the trailer has
several shots of saborship the beggar
which it looks like they're able to
raise from the water and get operational
so that they can travel around the
Galaxy we see several shots of them
doing that including ones where we see
salvor engaged in combat whatever
they're up to it looks like they're
going to run into some resistance from
the season 2 announcement we know that
Harry Gale and salvor discover a colony
of mentalx with psionic abilities that
threaten to alter psycho-history itself
I'd imagine this shot of Gail surrounded
by new characters is probably related to
that and some of the fighting I
mentioned could be two but based on the
terrain in situations they're in it also
looks like they visit multiple places
the voiceover has Gail talking about the
second crisis saying it's even bigger
than the last one and we also hear
salvor say that they need to be in the
fight it would make sense that his
tensions build between Empire and the
foundation that they might try to make
their way back toward Terminus but the
beggar is not a jump remember it
used to belong to Hugo who was much
older than he appeared because he had
spent a lot of time in cryosleep while
he was doing his runs if they are
traveling to multiple places then they
may be diverging from the other
storylines completely that seems like a
way that they could keep them involved
in the story for multiple seasons though
because unlike the cleons who have a new
clone added to their cycle every 30
years these two only have one Natural
Life to Live that's not to say I have
any idea what they're doing with it
based based on this trailer as mentioned
they're definitely doing some fighting
and the shots of this kid are really
interesting he seems like he might be
one of those mentaliks mentioned in the
season announcement but I can't say if
any of these other shots are directly
related to what's going on with him
location wise the mechs we see here and
that we're in the teaser probably are
but these other shots of this character
wearing goggles with fire in the
background and the characters in the
forest that salvor's fighting all might
be unrelated there's also a shot where
Gail's eyes are clouded over in a way
we've never seen before so I'm
interested in finding out what that is
for being a dead guy there's quite a lot
of Harry in this trailer but not really
any shots of him interacting with Gail
and salvor remember there are two
versions of Harry's Consciousness out
there the one that was contained in the
handle of Race's knife and the one in
the vault there's one shot of Harry
where he's physically smashing something
with the club or some other instrument
that is probably related to Gail but
most of the other shots where we see him
seem to be connected to the cleons we
hear Harry say for all of us to survive
we have to face them then later he says
we fight for peace not because we fear
we will lose but because we know that if
there is a war we will win this is being
delivered by a projection that looks
like it's appearing on trantor and
talking to brother day and while Harry
is saying that we see day who I imagined
by now is Cleon the 17th or 18th we see
him on Terminus approaching the Vault
and there is another shot where we see
the Vault opening so those are probably
related we also hear him say that the
foundation is a threat to him which of
course makes you think that he must have
just found out that Terminus wasn't
destroyed like they were led to believe
and that puts him on this path of
Destruction that we see playing out in
several of these shots there have also
been mentions of the Church of Selden
and I mentioned in my teaser breakdown I
thought these two characters in red
might be related to that since then I
went back and checked the casting
announcements and that does appear to be
the case this is Brother constant and
Paulie verisoff and it looks like day is
making an example out of them I don't
think this is the same Polly who was a
kid in season one because he would be
extremely old by this point on the story
but I guess who knows I mean he could be
a descendant or I could be totally wrong
about the timelines considering his
wrath has to be related to him finding
out for the first time that the
foundation is still out there that
Terminus still exists I still think it's
more likely that this is pretty far into
the future either way there is a lot of
day in this trailer and not much
explanation for how the Dynasty is
dealing with the problem of their
genetic Source material being corrupted
and the teaser we did see Queen sarath
coming to visit him there's not anything
new related to that in the trailer there
is a nice shot of all three of them with
demrazel in the throne room day is
standing there sort of looking over his
shoulder and in voiceover says that an
Empire breathes respect it requires it
for its life like the teaser there's not
a ton of demersell here there's one
really striking shot where she's looking
at something in space like something
Celestial there's kind of a fiery
reflection this could be them blowing
something up but it's hard to say there
are also a lot of shots of this new
character hober Malo who is someone who
featured in the books and some of his
scenes seem to be connected to these
floating robots or spacers I mean I went
back to look at the spacers from season
one and there are some similarities but
their eyes look totally different so if
I had to guess I'd be leaning towards
robots which aren't supposed to exist at
this time in the Empire Huber mallow did
start out as a traitor so this may be
related to technology and I just want to
say that it looks super cool but I
really don't know what is happening here
they seem to be floating and there seems
to be a lot of them so I hope this
happens pretty early in the season
because I'll be waiting to figure out
what it is there's also an interesting
shot of the Vault where you can see
hober malo's name projected on it so
again I hope we do get to find out
what's going on with this character
sooner rather than later there's also
some quick shots of the new character
Bell Rios who I mentioned is in the
first half of the second book in the
section titled the general if they're
following along with the book he
wouldn't come into play until later and
I guess it'll just come down to how much
time they go through in this season and
how many jumps ahead they have and if
they condense and combine some of these
stories together because in one of these
scenes it looks like we see hober Malo
and Bell Rios together and in this shot
where the character's not floating it
does look a lot like a robot speaking
about Rios this shot of the man with the
long hair that looks all disheveled
appears to be the same actor and even
though I can't think of a reason why
this would happen related to the books
it does appear to be him and if you can
trust the way that's cut together it
looks like demersell is going to
wherever he is to find him there's a lot
of cool stuff in here that I can't say
for sure how it's going to fit in
there's this shot of these charging
winged animals being chased by ships
where they take flight off of a cliff
based on a later shot that appears to be
on the same planet where we saw that kid
then there's this other shot of what
appears to be a male figure that's sort
of on display it's just sitting there
with these three connected circles we
see a young child approaching that who
could possibly be a brother dawn it
doesn't appear to be the same child
actor that we saw last season but he
would obviously be a lot bigger so I'm
not sure but we see him lurking around
this chamber which is all really
mysterious so to wrap it up it looks
like we're heading towards the second
crisis war between foundation and Empire
it does seem like Gail and salvor will
be off doing their own thing initially I
thought that would be related to the
second Foundation that Harry mentioned
whenever they were on the Raven but I
don't really see anything related to
Helicon which was where that was
supposed to be started but maybe things
have changed since he never arrived
there we'll see how close they stick to
the books the Church of Selden could
start to spread out that could start to
catch on or if they're going with the
Traders we might see them start to
secure some economic power and influence
that way but it does appear that once
the cleons learned that they're still
out there they they're going to be
gunning for them and it should be fun to
see how that plays out that seems like a
great place to leave things I am
planning to cover the whole season just
like I did for the first one please like
this video If you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon
thank you